[Musik]
die europäische union hat beschlossen
mehr geld für die sicherheit der
europäischen bürger bereit zu stellen
aus diesem grund gibt es den european
defence fand gefüllt mit 13 milliarden
euro
wir haben hier in brüssel einen experten
getroffen der den european defence fand
erklären kann und der selbst während der
vorsitzführung österreichs hier
wesentlich bei den verhandlungen
beitragen wird die europäische
verteidigung fonds ist ein fonds der
sich mit forschung und fähigkeiten
entwicklung in europa in
verteidigungsfragen beschäftigt ein
paradigmenwechsel im bereich der
kommission es wird geld in die hand
genommen 13 milliarden euro für die
nächsten jahre um vier
forschungsprojekte aber auch fähigkeit
ziele für die europa zu entwickeln
er wird im juni in straßburg vorgestellt
weitere maßnahmen sind dass es in einer
rats arbeitsgruppe behandelt wird nach
den abschlüssen dann versuchen wir noch
im november dieses jahres zu bekommen
sollte dann in den druck gehen dh eine
verhandlung mit europäischen parlament
kommission und den mitgliedstaaten damit
das ganze ein gesetzestext wird konkret
zu verhandeln geht es darum den bereich
forschung die verteidigungsforschung
aufzustellen und die bei der fähigkeit
entwicklung jene bereiche zu definieren
der zukünftige projekte die als menge in
europa definiert wurden abzuarbeiten und
die naht punkte
einbindung von drittstaaten es geht um
den finanzrahmen natürlich es geht um 6
sitzen
aber auch es geht um den bereich der
intelligence property was heißt die
informationen die in europa generiert
werden dass die ähnlich den ausverkauf
in europa stattfindet große chancen hat
österreich das hier
forschungseinrichtungen universitäten
aber auch betriebe im bereich der
forschung tätig werden können
hier werden programme und projekte bis
zu 100 prozent von der kommission
gefördert im bereich der fähigkeiten
entwicklung klein und mittelbetriebe im
grenzüberschreitenden einsatz hier bonus
zu bekommen das heißt eine subvention
damit sie mitmachen
große chancen für österreichische firmen
da wir sehr viele firmen haben in diesem
bereich arbeiten und hohe qualität hier
in brüssel aber auch weltweit genießen
eine chance eine große herausforderung
erfüllt mich mit stolz dass ich das
machen darf
ein blick nicht nur für unser baby pause
und gesamtstaatlich zu gewinnen und hier
dahingehend diesen fonds zu verhandeln
jetzt legen dann gerne